I am joined by my old friend Craig
Ferguson hey hey it's been a while it's
been like a year I used to work with
Craig on his serious show Craig Ferguson
radio show yeah that's a good times
wasn't it yeah Craig you were great
times and what's really weird is when we
work together on it I only really heard
Craig because he was in LA and I was in
New York so when I see you in person it
still feels very strange does it freak
you out a little bit to do that I do I
know it look like the way that you
imagined me and my DA feel like taller
or maybe weight over weight people
imagine me short it's I've had people
come up saying go away I thought you
were shorter I'm like eggs your TV any
sad yeah exactly
no yeah it's kind of frightening but
it's intimidating but and then I
realized how beautiful you are in person
okay and I calmed down
okay that's good as long as it has a
calming effect on you sometimes people
can be intimidated but you're okay I'm
okay and it hopes to were in your
beautiful hotel room seeing Central Park
yeah yeah so today's a big day for Craig
because he's his book riding the
elephant is out well that's not that I
mean that's happening but the big day is
I'm on your show big that's right sorry
my bad setup yeah but I have to say I
read this whole book the whole thing a
whole thing you're never gonna make it
in show business yeah unless you were
saying where everybody says that like
they say that they read the book no I'm
telling you okay the whole thing I have
time don't worry okay
so I realized reading this book that
it's very funny but it's also a really
good one two very serious oh yeah yeah
and I wanted to know when you were going
in to write this book how you approach
that like to get that blend like did you
want it to come off that way or was it
like oh I want to be this to be fully
serious er no I think what happens is
that you you write and it comes out the
way it's going to come out you just tell
the story the way is I think the great
freedom of writin something like this is
that if you feel like making an
observation which is neither funny nor
particularly upbeat you can write
no one's expecting it well if people are
expecting it to be funny all the time
then it's the wrong book I think what
sums up the book perfectly is there's
towards the end a chapter about you
going to Japan with your son Milo and
you talk about these Japanese toilets
they're amazing
now I laughed so hard the line you said
I left that bathroom a better man than
when I walked in so having that
experience how do you have that toilet
setup is it at your house now the same
kind of oh yeah yeah I know I have the
total can't remember the model number
but is that you walk in and the blue
light underneath and ready to accept
whatever you want to give it Wow
so yeah a beautiful thing so there's
hope for us Americans to get this in our
toilet I think that America if we want
to make America great again we have to
start with our our toilets and you know
I think we have to take a lesson from
Japan and get those robot toilets that
fire war directly at your people that's
that's what you need I agree this you
heard it here first
yeah but what defines a book to me is
that you throw in that historical
chapter but it's follows right after by
a chapter called draining the swamp
which to me was the darkest chapter of
the very dark job but it was the most
riveting to me
and it was interesting because you were
saying was in a time of Christmas 2017
into like January I remember we were
working on the show together for yes
yeah and I remember from working with
you that it seemed like you were upset
about something I didn't know what but
um but that's why for me reading it I
thought it was like really inspiring
that you opened up about what you were
going through yeah I'm just wondering
like was it tough writing a chapter like
that for you like did you hesitate like
[ __ ] I yeah I did I did that particular
one I I kind of like I wondered whether
or no I should go cuz it is very dark I
mean I go I go really down and weird and
and kind of started to thinking about
destroying myself which I haven't really
had that kind of thought since since I
was drinking so you know it was bad and
I having the dental surgery and I'm
taking the percocet and stuff nasty yeah
yeah nasty but I think it's so
inspirational that you got out of it and
that it shows people even like people
who are super famous and successful like
you go through stuff too and I think
that album yeah I think there's a myth
that somehow that I used to believe this
as well when I was a kid that I thought
if I if I get on TV but if I get famous
I won't have to go with the dentist
right I didn't like going to the dentist
and I was okay but you do still get root
canal so yeah but it's interesting cuz
you also bring up Twitter at this point
yeah and you always spoke about a lot on
the radio show and it says now in the
book that you let your manager or the
lovely Tomas Tomas he's the best
he handles it is that still the case
today oh sure yeah no I'm done social
media is not for me I it contains
it's that thing Trace Adkins said you
know it's not it doesn't it only takes
one person to take a dump in the pool
for it to be no an appetizing place for
me to spend time absolutely and I don't
I don't I think you see a lot more and
more people whenever I say to people
have not on social media or I don't have
a browser on my cell phone which I don't
there people go I envy you right you
know because I think everyone's starting
to feel that a little yeah no it's this
shit's too dark it's dark would you say
that it's also addictive like do you
think it's not yes I do I think for me
does I can't say for other pictures I
don't know who they are but but for me
yeah I think it has a because I found if
if by addictive you mean I find myself
doing it even although I didn't want to
do it then yes by definition that's
addictive oh right right yeah I mean I
think it's a good lesson for us and
especially for someone like me and my
generation Millennials like hearing it
from someone like you in a book I think
is great
and I think there's a strong
part of this writing you have here is
that you're very strong in your beliefs
but you're very open-minded I feel like
trying to and you try to look at new
beliefs people pop out there and what
you agree in disagree with you're very
honest so I was wondering when you were
writing this book did you have in your
mind anything about like I wonder how
Millennials might react to this chapter
what I'm saying like no no III don't I
don't think you can write a book
honestly and worried about why anyone's
gonna say when they read it right
I think I'm but I'm not I'm not focused
on Millennials and show you that
Millennials are focused on themselves
Millennials I believe you know what look
I'm not I don't you can't first of all
you can't take a generation of people
and say they're all the same that that's
absurd but the idea that that they're
better than or worse than any other
generation I know I don't subscribe to
that notion well I I I do think though
is that Millennials seem to be to take
themselves very seriously in a way which
the the generation coming after you guys
which is my oldest son's generation
they're not connected to all the to the
self regard and the way that you guys
are I think you're the first generation
of social media development and the next
generation of is they wear it very loose
okay and don't take it seriously and and
I actually I've noticed amongst Milo's
contemporaries they tend to stay in
their own groups sure so it's almost
like the it focuses back down to yeah I
don't really want to hear from you know
yeah
the weird creepy guy 24 so thick was my
friend so you think the generation after
me won't have their own YouTube channels
and doing all this I think they will I
think the I think they'll have their own
YouTube channels but I think the I think
they seem a little less for themselves
yeah I think I agree with that well I
think they're also it's there is the
Millennial thing was that this is a
phrase that we used to joke around with
on the radio show but they say all that
happened
before I was born sure that's a
millennial phrase people don't actually
say that in German history right because
human history so for example you know
the Roman Empire happened before I was
born
sure does it mean the Roman Empire
doesn't count to me on the contrary or
Oh contraire as they say in Canada the I
think that the this self regard is a
product of the first generation of
social media smartphone users I think
the next generation are adapting to much
better ok I like that and I think that
like that also leads to just like we
need to my generation has to not forget
about our history and learn from it you
know far be it from me to say you know I
the trapezes you get older start you
know condemn in the youth and I don't
I'm not interested in that it's a great
line and the little boy song changes
these children that you spit on as they
try to change their world there's no
there's no I'm not trying to spit on you
as you try to change your world I feel
you crying I look you're coming out very
gentle and I love it and I understand
and I'm a thing - I just want to bring
up you talk about in the book and I love
that you haven't but you're big fan of
ink now in tattoos oh yeah well I
thought so interesti she brought up that
you have this thing that someone kind of
put on you with the having the odd
number of tattoos at any given time yeah
and then when you I read that I looked
at my tattoos I was like do I have an
odd number and I feel like it's on me
now do you huh yeah well that's your
thank God yeah that's the thing with OCD
magical thinking that stank gets on you
real fast it just crawls it the minute
you get rid of some of it another part
of it crawls up your spine is bad yeah
like I I i only recently got rid of this
magical Underpants I had to wear on the
airplane I'm only talking the last three
flights yeah you know but they were
falling off me these things happen yeah
so Craig thank you for joining me this
has been a great this has been the best
of this press tour
yes this is the greatest show in
American media guy whoo
drew make sure it's out today riding the
elephant the book and you'll have to buy
if you don't wanna buy it's a book I
just I want you to know it's there if
you want to buy it but please don't buy
if you don't wanna buy
you're not gonna anyway so I I'm not
gonna try and you know I have
unrealistic expectations about where
you're gonna do if you're gonna buy it
you're gonna buy it if you're not gonna
buy it you're not gonna buy I'm not
gonna change your mind I understand that
can they torn it come on your book can
they download the audio oh yeah I think
there's gotta be an audiobook cuz I
spent days reading that [ __ ] in her
microphone so yeah ok cool that should
be fun yeah alright well Craig till next
time I see you maybe in a year two years
three years oh I think six months six
months yeah we got a thing coming out in
about six months so we'll be back in six
months I'll do that there will you still
be on the air I hope so is it you on a
youtube youtube this YouTube I hope they
don't kick me off YouTube well they're
getting stricter Berthe are you or are
you very right-wing no I don't put
politics and you're good I'm clear yeah
thanks guys
alright